m
c'est bien
quatre adeptes de l'alimentation sept
jeunes ont préparé ensemble un repas qui
illustre ce quel ordi est au quotidien
c'est avec une crème d'avocat froide et
crevettes épicé qu'ils débutent leur
repas c'est excellent moyen a paru en
1920 les dyades cétogène s'avère un
traitement médical efficace pour traiter
l'épilepsie pédiatrique
elle est aujourd'hui très à la mode pour
stimuler la perte de poids première
semaine je perds cinq les finalement
j'en suis à 58 livre de perdus alors moi
j'ai perdu 94 livre ce après peu près un
an était proche du diabète proche du
cholestérol et après 14 94 livre je n'ai
plus de médicaments j'ai regagné ma vie
j'ai regardé ma santé je vous en prie
la diète c'est au jeune et la plus
restrictive des diètes faible en
glucides
on évite donc les fruits trop sucrés
comme les poires ils me l'ont les
raisins et les légumes racines trop
riches en amidon karine gravel docteur
en nutrition analyser la littérature
scientifique au sujet du régime cétogène
et un s'inquiète du menu des ghettos
comme il aime se nommer donc beaucoup
d'aliments éviter même le groupe produit
céréalier qui est bannie au complet donc
peu de fruits des légumes aussi qui sont
retirés pas de légumineuses donc c'est
de tous des aliments sains dont les
bienfaits sur la santé sont démontrés
une faune est pas croyable d'en manger
tous à pied de perdre du poids
classique dans ce régime
les glucides ne représente que 10% de
l'énergie quotidienne soit 20 g
c'est l'équivalent d'une banane ou de yo
gourd par jour jusqu'à enfin il faut
descendre les glucides pour augmenter
les grands parce que le carburant change
d'allégeance dans cette diète les
lipides eux représentent 75 % des
calories quotidiennes ingéré en
comparaison une alimentation habituelle
fournit environ 30 % de notre énergie à
partir des lipides et 50% des glucides
moi quand j'ai commencé la première
journée chaude en un brunch avec ma
famille je servirai avec des oeufs
bénédictine avec du fromage briques du
vécu j'ai dit je suis la diète ce
peugeot grâce à cet apport en gras les
adeptes de la diète cétogène affirme ne
pas ressentir la privation et être
rassasié après le repas il faut aussi
avoir l'esprit plus vifs je te reste des
journées de 12 heures plus je dirais qu
au bout de douze ans j'ai encore la même
énergie mentale encore aussi allumé que
je t'ai quand j'ai commencé le matin
sans glucides le corps doit puiser son
énergie dans les grappes pour produire
des corps cétoniques créant ainsi un
état de septoriose et notre corps est
pas habitué à fonctionner comme cela a
été plus facile pour lui disant d'aller
chercher l'énergie sous forme de lui
c'est donc là on lui demande comme un
effort supplémentaire et on estime qu'au
début de la diète
on pourrait dépenser 500 calories par
jour le court utilisé en fait produire
des corps six thoniers petty et utilisé
c'est trop de formes d'énergie en fait
c'est le mélange du sucre et du grog est
pas bon pour la santé
quand on élimine les glucides legros
devient intéressant mais pour karine
gravel tous les glucides ne sont pas à
éviter
au contraire il faut faire la
distinction entre le sucre et les
glisser dans un aliment peut être riche
en glucides parce qu'il est riche en
fibres alimentaires puisque les fibres
alimentaires
on n'a plus besoin de deux d'études pour
doudoune démontrer les bienfaits
ceux qui adoptent ce régime maintiennent
que leur consommation de légumes n'a
jamais été aussi importante
je mange beaucoup de légumes ce que ça
composent gerin environ 75 à 80% de me
glisser le journal ce sont les légumes
revivez les nutritionnistes s'inquiète
des effets à long terme de la
consommation de mauvais gras lié aux
maladies cardiovasculaires
si notre apport en aliments d'origine
animale en viande augmente puis on fait
aussi la promotion de la crème du beurre
dans qu'un moment donné on sait que plus
on augmente les gras saturés mais plus
on reste tellement d'augmenter aussi
notre cholestérol ldl qui connu comme le
mauvais cholestérol piano qui ont peur
pour nous autres parce qu'on mange du
véhicule des charcuteries mais au début
c'est ça quand tu commences attali
mentez pas manger les fromages de scott
plus gros les triple crème prestige de
bourgogne par exemple c'est se dit jojo
pète offrir n'est finalement pas du
poids des temps sans engrais et nos
actes en fait personne ne se basent sur
leur expérience personnelle qui est
positive mais avant d'émettre des
recommandations et par exemple le
dernier des nutritionnistes dont va se
baser sur des données scientifiques
les diététistes ont besoin d'études
réalisées sur de longues périodes pour
établir leurs recommandations je pense
que c'est sécurisant pour la population
datant d'avant des études avant de
recommander certaines certaines
pratiques parce que c'est quand même pas
une diète qui qui est analysée mais il
ya quand même des effets secondaires
sérieux
le cardiologue martin juneau s'est
exprimée maintes fois sur la diète
cétogène et considère que ce n'est pas
nécessairement une mauvaise diapos il le
suggère à des patients tout en y mettant
certaines réserves des gens qui ont
vraiment un surpoids important qui n'ont
jamais réussi à perdre du poids alors à
ce moment là on leur dit qu'ils peuvent
faire à condition que les gros sont de
très bonne qualité
un fait demeure plusieurs perdre du
poids et certains peuvent améliorer les
aspects de leur santé je conseille
d'être accompagné par un professionnel
la santé pour eux poursuit cette lettre
le mais en même temps je doute diatement
qui ont montré des effets positifs
solaire
cardiovasculaires comme l'alimentation
méditerranéenne par exemple un panel
d'experts américain a d'ailleurs établi
un classement des meilleurs diète pour
perdre du poids
prévenir le diabète et les maladies
cardiovasculaires la diète cétogène
arrive en 38e position sur 41 tandis que
la diète méditerranéenne se classe au
premier rang
[Applaudissements]